when you go to like uh when you when you
travel around how much research do you
do you do to a place before you like
travel there I mean research is in like
in in the language in anything you know
um like very little you know language
wise I'll probably learn how to order
that's and then yeah yeah I don't
because I normally you know I'll maybe
learn like basic readings like Hello
thank you yeah yeah stuff like that but
yeah I'm not gonna learn like just
enough instructions hopefully not be a
nuisance yeah yeah um but then obviously
when you check into hotels and stuff
you'd like okay please have hopefully
please have English yeah yeah because I
I had this when I went to Vietnam
because it's been like quite a while
since I had just traveled to a new
country that I had just never been to
before and it was just like a quick
weekend trip so I didn't actually do
that much research uh after I uh after I
got off the plane and I was like oh [__]
uh do they is is English as common here
as it is in Thailand [__] I don't
actually know I didn't I didn't bother
learning any Vietnamese phrases because
I'm just here for the weekend [__] uh so
like it's it was just like that kind of
realization of just oh I'm that dumb
tourist now [__]
I I am actually that dumb tourist now
right it's it's a feeling that I I guess
like I've forgotten for a while because
most of the time when I travel it's like
[__] America or like other
English-speaking countries you know so I
think like the mentality I go into it is
like say like you know a couple months
ago I went to Korea for the first time
right where it's like you know mo in
Korea most people can speak English yeah
at least did you know that beforehand
though or uh I'd heard about it okay but
you know they say that about a lot of
countries yeah yeah true right so you
know I went in there ex you know being
like all right well you know what I'm
probably not gonna bother like you know
learning
you know a lot of like extensive phrases
or anything in Korean but I'll just
learn the basics and then when I get
there I'll try and learn as much of it
as I can like I'm much rather in the in
in this headspace of like it's better to
even to be that dumb tourist at least to
show that you want to kind of learn the
language and I think that is just as uh
appreciated by the locals then you
already knowing it right so like there
were so many times where if I knew that
like you know the I'd go to a random
food stall in in Seoul and the guy would
be speaking to me in English I would
just be like how do you say this in
Korean yeah and the guy was very happy
to like teach me how to say it and you
know when I would reflect back on it
he'd be like yeah there you go you got
it yeah so I think like just showing no
matter what you know the you know no
matter how it is just showing that you
are interested in it I think is what
will get the locals to be like all right
cool you know what I respect that and I
think the only reason why that doesn't
work as much in Japan as it does in say
Korea is because a lot of Japanese
people are a little bit afraid of
reserved and reserved to talk to
foreigners and tourists whereas in Korea
they're a lot more open about it yeah
being like yeah you know you're you're a
tourist yeah I see Taurus all the
[__] time well you know I'll teach
you some words yeah yeah did you find
out like when you went on your Euro trip
like this is like pre-pandemic because
you went to like a lot of different
countries yeah you know like a very very
short period of time but I guess you had
like a guide right well yeah we went to
like six or yeah six different European
countries all for the first time but
yeah we because it was me and Aki's
first time in Europe so we were like I'd
rather go to a country where I have like
a friend living there like like show me
around so like I had my local friend
with me there but also you know I did
the same thing where like whenever I
would be served something yeah I would
ask the store clerk or whatever to be
like how do you say this in French or
Italian or you know what whatever
country I'm in and I think for the most
part it they seem to appreciate it right
yeah yeah I guess yeah being do I
remember any of them no you remember for
that one trip sometimes sometimes you
just fly somewhere you're like maybe
I'll just you quickly Google so when I
was in Finland I learned so much [__]
finish I couldn't tell you a single
[__] finish phrase right now
is when you're a tourist it's like as
long as you're not being a dick yeah
yeah I think it doesn't really matter I
think I think there's nothing wrong with
being the dumb tourist I think the
problem lies in being the Arrogant dumb
tourist of like you're not open-minded
enough to like involve yourself in the
culture that's when you kind of get the
stink eye but if if you're like you can
be the dumb tourist just be like the
Curious dumb tourists I think it's just
looking up maybe like what the general
kind of etiquette is on certain places
before you turn up is probably just yeah
yeah you can watch a [__] top 10 list
of things to do and don't do yeah like
you know in Japan and every other
country on Earth probably yeah just
tells you hey this is this is a cool
thing to do this is definitely not cool
thing to do like I think that's just you
know that helps yeah I look into that
for sure because the last thing I want
to do is be the dumb tourist that also
offends the country I mean you know yeah
I think as long as you're you know
polite I think whatever yeah yeah I mean
you know
you know ultimately there's nothing
wrong with being a tourist of course
yeah because you [__] have to be yeah
um everyone's a tourist yeah but you
know I think it's just hey if you're
chill who cares okay as an Australian
right so in England I don't know if this
is just uh
I don't know if this is just like a
British thing but one thing I've noticed
is you know as a Brit every time I see
like a Brit abroad like making a [__]
fool of themselves which I've seen
terrible so many times I'm like
England's got the worst tourist in the
world and then I was like I was talking
to Sydney and she's like no Americans
are the worst tourists in the world and
then I you know I one time I like made a
french guy and he thinks they're the
worst stories in the world as an
Australian do you think you are like the
worst tourist in the world yeah
it depends because it's like it depends
on the location with Australians right
because I think Australians in like say
Tokyo or Osaka uh for the most part
pretty all right yeah but say Australian
tourists at ski resorts
yeah like you know I worked with them
and I can 100 say they're the worst
because like it's it's I think it's like
Australian I think a lot of Australian
tourists because you know for the most
part we're very very Multicultural
country so we're just living in
Australia unless you're living in like
the butt [__] middle of nowhere you're
most likely going to run into different
cultures right whether you like it or
not so I think for the most part
Australians who live in cities are
naturally inclined to understand that
there are cultural differences wherever
you go right not just language
differences but I don't know what it is
about the the atmosphere of a ski resort
in Japan that just makes Australians go
yeah [__] the culture I'm here to rip
the snow dogs
like hotels are kind of like a dorm in a
way yeah yeah it feels like you know a
lot of these like ski lodges they do
kind of like uh have more of like a
western feel of like just come in it's
casual you know hang out with the people
in the lounge area oh they're all
Australians as well you guys will get
along fine go you know rip it in the
snow whatever yeah yeah but then they
take that energy to the nearby Village
yeah and the nearby cities and it's just
like I because I remember when I worked
in hakuba I would you know frequently go
into uh like Nagano and like nigata to
do some work and you'll see those exact
same like ski bro Australians in these
cities yeah oh wow
because the the two main ski resorts are
in Niger and you'd go into the cities
and you would see the the ski Bros there
and they're just some of the most
loudest most obnoxious tourists I've
ever met I'm just like bro we're not in
the ski lodges anymore we're in a city
with hundreds of terrified Japanese
people calm down keep it in the logs
yeah I mean I I guess I just noticed as
well normally when when I make when I
meet like British people in Japan they
can come to Japan most of them are like
pretty chill right all of them shelves
for some reason
every time I see uh especially English
tourists especially in like southeast
Asia in Thailand I I'm I saw it as a
reputation oh I saw so many in when I
went to Vietnam and every time I heard
the English accent I'm like I do not
know this
[Music]
yeah I mean I think there's certain
destinations that yeah let's say uh more
bang for your buck money yeah I think
attract a certain type of British
tourist yeah and probably other European
tourists too but mainly British ones
like like what's like the main like I
guess party country or Party location
for like British people it's like Ibiza
a lot of like the Spanish Island some of
the Greek Islands because in Australia
that's Bali so when you go to Bali I've
personally never been to Bali before but
I've heard stories of just like the most
obnoxious Australians in Bali just like
[__] trying to make it like there are
because you can buy them like extremely
cheap transport
a cheap accommodation and with like the
party atmosphere yeah extremely cheap
alcohol yeah yeah which is like I guess
like Vietnam and Thailand that are
pretty cheap yeah and drinking well I
saw I saw so many people from Essex in
Vietnam
there was this one girl who was uh
clearly from Essex
um like having having an argument with
like one of like the Vietnamese
bartenders like over like the price of
this beer or something which the price
of this beer was about one dollar and
she was like no no no like I I got two
for one two for one and she was like
shouting at this waiter and then I I I
don't know I was like signing of like
five minutes and the waiter just comes
up to me and just goes I [__] hate
English girls and I was just like I was
just like hmm
I had that in Japan I was I was in an
Izakaya and this like group of like four
young Australians like walk in yeah
um and I could immediately hear from
their accents not from the city yeah
yeah so there's like sit down they're so
[__] loud even though we're Indian
izakai with lots of people I can hear
them like clearly like they're sitting
next to me and I remember remember this
[__] like the waiter comes over you
know ask for whatever they're ordering
drinks and then they're ordering food
and this [__] girl just like goes oh
so the uh the fried chicken
um is it free range
and I'm just sitting there like
bro you're in you're in a [__] kidney
why are you expecting fine dining in a
[__] dirt cheap Izakaya and I just
started laughing I'm like huh to the
waiter in like the most Aussie accent
clearly this guy doesn't understand
right he's just like oh sorry I think
I've even explained you explain it
perfect Japanese you'd be like the [__]
you talking yeah so what is that what
does that mean what are you [__]
talking about friendly
and she just like and she just it kept
going on and on and on being like if
it's not free range I don't really want
to eat it
and I'm like
just like just don't even bother just go
to go to a fancy restaurant
peacefully yeah or if it died by a hands
of a man like you're one you're one step
away from being like Oh so um is is this
meal vegan or uh you know just [__]
oh my God I'm like dude okay I get that
you have like you know you might have
like dietary issues like you know if you
want to know like oh does this have
peanuts because I have a peanut allergy
or something like so you're in the
cheapest Izakaya yeah in the middle of
Tokyo yeah do not expect free-range
chickens man it's probably getting paid
like five dollars an hour to serve you
he's not getting paid enough so bad
because the guy had to go back and like
get like uh clearly like a staff
understood a little bit more English
yeah and just like this argument just
it's same it seemed like it went off for
ages and it's just like this manager is
trying to tell them being like okay so
uh not gonna lie we don't know if it's
free range chicken but we can guarantee
it's good it's tasty probably
Frozen it's 400 Yen I don't know what
you're complaining about and this girl
just kept going on and on and I'm just
like dude come on man like yeah why why
are you doing this so yeah Australian
tourists
one thing one thing I'll say about
American tourists The Stereotype is that
American tourists are the loudest
tourists yeah and I don't know if that's
necessarily true but for some reason a
merit like every time I see an American
Tourist abroad whatever country it's in
for some reason they always have the
most recognizable voice in any
establishment have you noticed this I
don't know why every American I've seen
in Japan has been super polite yeah no
they have yeah yeah
it's very easy to hear them out yeah
yeah for some reason it could be like
the loudest like bar you've ever been to
and you'll just hear that one American
accent that will pierce through
everything being said this cocktail's
[__] delicious it's just like I don't
know if it's because like we just
consume so much American Media yeah but
it's an instantly recognizable kind of
we hear so much American accents that
when we hear in real life we're like oh
I can immediately hear that yeah I don't
know I I can't put my hand on do you
have that like level of I don't know if
you guys have it for like for British
tourists but like do you have that like
split moment where you hear that British
accent you just like like
kinfolks I have that with Australia yeah
yeah most definitely most definitely
except if it's in Southeast Asian in
which case it's probably I should avoid
them they hate my man's I'm tired for
the day I only speak Thai you don't see
a lot of British people in Japan though
it's kind of right yeah you don't all
Americans yeah which is why which is why
everybody I've met here has been pretty
cool so far pretty chill you have to
like Japan to to want to go here yeah as
a British tourist yeah it's literally
the other side of the world it's like
it's like a 20-hour flight That's True
14-hour Flight like it's it's long
that's how I feel about Australians in
Europe yeah
all right you must really like Europe if
you're gonna sit on a plane for 22 hours
all right let's think about Europe is if
you don't like one of the countries
you're like right I guess I'll take the
20 minute ride cab ride to the next one
that's true yeah yeah oh you didn't like
Liechtenstein well you lucky for you
you're a five minute walk away from
anywhere else just across the road yeah
you'll literally get to go like wherever
you want to go oh my God